eq à violaines guerre en immunologie ce
collectif qu'ovide 19 laissons les
médecins à prescrire bonsoir viola dira
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france vous avez toujours défendu l'
usage la prise de ce médicament sur
notre antenne on a eu d'ailleurs un
débat récent houleux avec laurent
alexandre ici même
aujourd'hui ce médicament est interdite
en france jusqu'à nouvel ordre votre
réaction
écoutez gérer dans le même sens ce crime
ce raout que je ne connais pas précises
mais par rapport à la réalité actuelle
du terrain c'est à dire que nous ne
voyons plus de patients atteints de kovy
deux à l'heure actuelle en médecine
libérale
donc par rapport à ce qui est notre
notre devoir de traiter des patients
avec un traitement efficace et qui a
clairement fait ses preuves pour les
gens qui n'ont utilisé parce que c'est
ça qui est important aussi c'est de
devoir l'expérience que les gens ont de
cette molécule de ce traitement du
traitement de l'asie trop messine seul
également pour pouvoir donner un avis
éclairé
donc cette molécule ne va pas nous faire
défaut là la seconde près en revanche il
est clair que nous devons récupérer
cette liberté de prescription qui est
tout à fait indispensable est bon ce qui
peut peut-être nous tranquilliser c'est
que des études arrivent en phase précoce
avec ce traitement dhea aujourd'hui
aussi communiquer sur un une nouvelle
étude en cours de publication avec plus
de 3700 patients donc j'espère que
raison garder nous allons pouvoir ne
plus être bientôt le seul pays du monde
à interdire cette molécule dans le vide
et violaine guérin comment vous
expliquer aujourd'hui cette interdiction
c'est cette fameuse étude dont on a
beaucoup parlé paru vendredi
seul un set une étude très critique
envers cette molécule la faute donc à
cette étude vous pensez je pense que si
c'était une été analysés siens
les joints par l'état français il n'y
aurait aucune raison de d'interdire des
drogues cyktor hockin donc je pense
qu'il ya des choses qui nous dépassent
et là je dirais que moi je suis assez
centré sur le soin et que ça va
peut-être fatale vous justement les
journalistes d'essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe parce que la situation est
tout à fait surréaliste
l'étude est complètement 10 et lé groupe
ne sont pas comparables elles et elles
émanent d'une base de données de de gens
qui sont essentiellement des
cardiologues et avec des des patients
qui ont des complications cardiaques
importante bien plus que dans la
population un standard on n'arrive pas à
savoir d'ailleurs qu'elle est la liste
des hôpitaux dans laquelle on a récupéré
des données les des scientifiques confié
la publication n'ont pas eu un seul
patient atteint de deux co vide
il ya beaucoup de choses qui interpelle
en fait à votre connaissance puisque
vous le précisez bien en brousse et le
soin qui nous intéresse à votre
connaissance est ce qu'un patient a eu
des complications graves
après la prise diderot xi chloroquine
écoutez nous sommes plusieurs médecins
dans le collectif à avoir soigné des
patients comme ça avant le décret du 26
qui nous a empêchés d'avoir accès la
molécule nous avons tous été extrêmement
surpris de l'efficacité de ce médicament
qui a permis souvent une rétablissement
de l'état clinique extrêmement rapide et
je pense que tous les pays qui ont testé
cette molécule lavaud le joaillier dans
votre reportage en parlait du du brésil
eh bien je vois que des pharmaciens du
brésil sont en train de vivre des
ruptures pareil en france on a très peu
parlé de l'étude de brésilienne de
barbosa et collaborateurs qui sont des
médecins de terrain qui ont prescrit
extrêmement tôt cette association et qui
ont des eu d'excellents résultats c'est
ça qui explique que les pharmacies sont
vides au brésil j'étais aussi contente
de voir par rapport à l'algérie la
presse de deux décisions des autorités
algériennes
et dans le collectif nous avons un
pharmacien particulier tac gérer qui
nous renvoie des informations donc il
faut qu'on arrive à comprendre
effectivement ce qui se passe dans ce
pays
quels sont les enjeux en éthique de
l'aisne guérin content que vous écoutez
quand on a vu le sujet effectivement
beaucoup de pays préconisent même cette
molécule sénégal d'ailleurs des sites ce
soir de continuer à prescrire les
drogueries chloroquine ça veut dire quoi
qu'il ya un principe de précaution
vraiment ont poussé à l'extrême en
france on a une spécificité française
rapidement parce que j'ai deux questions
vous poser mais je pense pas que ce soit
du tout le principe de précaution parce
que c'est totalement irrationnel et en
plus si c'était le principe de
précaution n'aurait pas restreint usage
de l'hydroxyte lock in avec le décret du
26 mars aux patients les plus graves
parce que c'était précisément à eux
qu'il fallait pas ne pas la donner
donc il ya des choses qui ne sont
absolument pas scientifique en dessous
je sais pas quels sont les intérêts
politiques économiques outre mais sur le
plan médical pur c'est n'est pas normal
c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup
d'intérêts financiers notamment les
laboratoires c'est quelque chose qui me
booste paraît pas saugrenue vous en tant
que médecin je pense que c'est
multifactoriel
je pense qu à l'évidence il ya des
désintérêt de laboratoires et des
intérêts de l'om est puisque j'ai été
confronté avec une une responsable de
l'om est sur un sujet que je connais
bien puisque comme vous le dites j'ai
des compétences en immunologie où elle
déclarait que le que des gens là n'est
pas immunisé que le virus n'avait pas
permettre la formation d'anticorps
neutralisants et c'est ce qui est
vraiment n'importe quoi et d'ailleurs ça
se confirme entre autres avec les
données qu'on a élu hier pour la france
avec une très bonne immunisation des
soignants donc il ya de la
désinformation et dans quel but voilà je
pense que c'est multifactoriel non plus
ma dernière question elle s'éloigne
peut-être un de la question justement
des soins mais évidemment on peut se la
poser le professeur à holt a émergé
durant cette crise sanitaire comme un
nouveau héros des anti système c'est
lui-même qui se positionnent
ainsi opposants souvent le bon sens la
pratique faso aux constructions
intellectuelles des élites est ce qu'ils
payent aujourd'hui en tout cas vous
savez ce sentiment il paye son
positionnement
moi je crois qu'on me sort out il est
droit dans ses bottes j'ai entendu
effectivement son interview il n'y a pas
grand chose qui va pouvoir qu'il veut le
chambouler j'ai été très intéressé
d'entendre que à chaque fois qu'il avait
fait des découvertes importantes et des
noeuds ce n'est pas la première fois il
avait toujours été extrêmement shalit
est donc pour lui ce n'est qu'un chahut
de plus est
et qu'est ce qui est évident pour moi
c'est pour les patients parce que je
pense qu'en france on aurait pu éviter
des morts je pense qu'on aurait pu
probablement évité de confinement de
toute une population
si on avait été prêt pour confiner des
patients malades et pour faire les tests
et autres donc énormément de
traumatismes qui en sont des
conséquences et là je rentre de
consultations toute la journée des
patients sont extrêmement perturbées par
ce qui s'est passé et avec des mêmes des
états dépressifs des angoisses et on n'a
pas fini de mesurer toutes les
répercussions de cette stratégie qu'il
ya eu
merci beaucoup et lionel guérin
immunologiste d'avoir été avec moi en
direct sur rt france